mais un morceau qui claquent si jamais
on doit [__] le boxon
bon je vous explique
j'ai devant moi une prochaine de
virtuoses du larcin est bien sûr notre
petit mozart du karting
le public raffole des histoires de
braquage de banque à leur cerveau lors
quelque chose d'éclatants et d'explosifs
art qu'elles pourront évoquer autour
d'un café latté que ce qui ne coûte
maintenant on va voir
tequila
[Applaudissements]
y'a d'quoi de bananes et de tequila
[Musique]
on a déjà dit tu es un petit veinard
paraison bebig
oh
[Musique]
ça mérite un oscar c'est aubry
c'est sûr
désolé madame
[__]
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
on colle le temps c'est pas le même je
te parle pas de la météo je te parle des
deux heures interminables que tu vas
passer avec la crème des cassos de son
lycée j'te pinta mer
[Musique]
t'es pas un looser t'y vas tu lui parles
est la sortie tu les chocs et tu viens
souvent encore louis tous les amis
j'adore mais rien à faire dans ma vie
ah ouais d'accord tu as un petit détour
en fait ça ok c'est une blague
bon les deux ensemble à faire mais
logent nous sépare
il ya quelque chose de bizarre merci
c'est quoi tout ce que je vis j'ai déjà
vécu
voire les 2 en forme la paire mais là je
ne sais pas et chaque fois que je mets
langdell puis trois minutes
je reviens systématiquement au début de
la côte à 92 et du coup bah je suis
bloqué ça c'est marrant ça ouais c'est
vrai c'est pas très bon
il est collé à vis d'un film est-il
honnête et salah sont toutes pourries
on dit pourrit pas pourri que les salles
sont pour its qu'on accorde le sujet
avec sa mère toutes les communautés
pente est douce
[Musique]
il faut que je trouve une fin à cette
histoire ferait pas une idée du temps là
souvent non mais là j'ai rien là c'est
ce que je craignais
[Applaudissements]
non qu'ils échouent pour 3 minutes
d'ottawa total le tuf et marcal où la
ferme ta gueule
c'est qui le patron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourri si les pizzas oui
[Musique]
mais non
tiens mon frère
quand il quoi au juste un bon à mon bras
droit
thales a jamais eu autant de succès avec
elfi que quand j'étais petit j'ai pas
d'alex mais qu'un toi t'es chez les
siens 4 c'est là bas
[Musique]
uniqlo paris
faites attention parce qu'ils s'y colle
ondes ça veut dire que notre copie ça
promet les vacances
c'est sur facebook et twitter timber
grinder bon allez la tong on se lave les
dents et au lit je dis on va en boîte
alors au programme de ce matin conseil
partir pour cuba
tu sais qu'on peut régler remet à
vaincre
[Musique]
singuluma parole ouverte aux salaires
plantaire
de boules quiès super et une boîte de
préservatifs sur un panneau
[Applaudissements]
tu dois absolument reprendre l'avantagé
avec ses études venge mec ça veut dire
que tu veux ça donne quoi tu joues mais
pour veiller sur eux ils vacances où ses
fans vacances
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous venons de subir une véritable
débâcle
nous irons jusqu'au bout
jamais nous nous rendrons
un appel a été lancé aux doit aller à
dunkerque
paré a largué les amarres qu'est ce que
vous faites vous vous rendez compte où
on va on a le cap sur la guerre vous
serez utile monsieur c'est un délit il
m'a dit
la ligne
je n'en reviens pas s'en aller allez on
descend
il faut que les envois d'autres
vaisseaux
chaque heure qui passe les week-ends du
terral
ils ont réquisitionné les pattes au
civil les bras au ciel il faut des
destroyers
où il croit à dunkerque
j'y retourne pas et a laissé mourir
vous êtes des plaisanciers ne tue pas la
royal navy pouvez rentrer chez vous
ou ceux des rampes à sa fille on a un
boulot à faire virer pas
nous nous battrons sur les plages nous
nous battrons sur les pistes d'aviation
jamais nous nous rendrons
jaloux
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent djia perd
[Musique]
la généalogie terre contre le pot
à la pause tout sauf km
[Musique]
son
en patois c'est quand même un peu
plus que de mac os x
et ce n'est pas pour la première sur nos
corps
[Musique]
la mécanique est sans doute plus
souffrir
cette année
au delà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]